so age 18 him and his brother get on a
plane they go to Hong Kong and they're
like we are going to start our Toy
Factory here in Hong Kong they get their
first night he literally sleeps in a
bush because they didn't have like you
know a place to stay that night so you
see something why wouldn't he just do a
sidewalk too hard bro he you know you
don't want to sleep on the ground you
know you want to sleep on on a bush so
he sleeps on a bush outside be normal
use the bench
[Music]
all right we live I got something good
for you I got a crazy story in fact this
is a billy of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
ten dollars isn't cool you know it's
cool a billion dollars
uh you know sometimes we get a little
fast and lose with the Billy of the week
where it's not a real Billy this guy is
a real billionaire okay so have you ever
heard the name Nick mowbray
no
okay so Nick bobray here's the here's my
headline for this University Dropout
from New Zealand becomes a billionaire
with zero dollars invested okay so what
what happened
um I'll click yeah you clicked all right
here's here's the next bit
two brothers
um when they were in I think Middle
School they enter a science fair and in
the science fair they create a hot air
balloon modeling kit and they end up
winning the science fair so here's Nick
12 years old wins the science fair and
he decides all right people really liked
my hot air balloon kit that my like
model hot air balloon kit I'm gonna go
selfie so he goes to start selling them
door to door and he opens up a farm a
little like Factory in his his family's
Farm uh to like build the kits uh as
he's going but like he's having trouble
scaling up because he's trying to do
production himself and uh and he's doing
the sales himself and it's like okay
this is tough
so age 18 him and his brother get on a
plane they go to Hong Kong and they're
like we are going to start our Toy
Factory here in Hong Kong they get their
first night he literally sleeps in a
bush because they didn't have like you
know a place to stay that night so you
see something why wouldn't he just do a
sidewalk
too hard bro you know you don't want to
sleep on the ground you know so when you
sleep on on a bush so he sleeps on a
bush outside be normal use the bench
they end up getting a apartment that I
think was eight dollars a month
um and that was their their apartment
they start a factory this was now maybe
uh 15 years ago-ish something like that
and so they're in a very small city in
China and so not they're not in Hong
Kong anymore so they they end up
creating a a factory so here's the
factory so they they create a factory
Nick ends up sleeping in the factory for
eight years and um they had 13 000 to
their name that was what their parents
loaned them uh to start this business
and so they're like um
they're like how do we make this work
and so they they want to create
um this like kind of toy company and so
they're like all right and so they do
they start doing two things number one
they're like all right we only have this
much money and now we're living in China
we gotta like make this stretch so these
guys are like doing all the like you
know the hustle porn stories you hear
for entrepreneurship they're doing it
where he's like we used to eat only off
the dollar menu at McDonald's in China
and he's like every day he's like for
Christmas we would go get the Big Mac
and it was like two dollars and change
and that was our celebration
um he's like I would eat half my fries
and then I would go back to the counter
and be like hey this is like I'm not
even full that's awesome full container
of fries he's like that's how we did it
he's like we had the Thirteen thousand
dollars from our our parents and then we
had to make this work and so they end up
creating a bunch of
um you know fast forward till today they
have
um
they have basically like uh the like
they do a billion dollars a year in
sales on their toy company this guy is
personally a self-made billionaire
they've created toys uh zuru
z-u-r-u and so they've created a bunch
of toys that you've heard of like Robo
Fish I don't know if you've ever heard
of that it's like a like a little fake
it's a toy fish that'll swim around in a
jar or like a fishbowl
um they've created a bunch of balloons
which I've bought this a bunch of times
it's like you could you put the hose in
it'll fill up a bunch of water balloons
all at once
um and so they they you know the dark
Blaster they've sold 39 million of these
or whatever and so they basically built
all these
um
like hit viral toys and so and early on
what they did like at the beginning what
they did was they basically just knock
off other good toys like gimmick toys
and they would just make them themselves
and try to like out execute them so they
were like trying to out manufacture them
or out distribute them so there'd be
like a light up frisbee that was like
hot so he they would like clone the
light up Frisbee and then they would go
and they would like like to get into
retail stores they crashed the like the
buyer's dinner for Dick's Sporting Goods
and his sister just like showed up and
kind of like schmoozed her way in and
got the account and they just did that
over and over and over again they you
know they and they would get sued by the
companies like hey you're copying our
toys they're like oh yeah okay we gotta
create original toys and so they kind of
knocked it off they they brute force
their way into retail and then they
started creating the original toys like
bunch of balloons of Robo Fish and the
stuff and so basically
um they uh you know they would basically
sell these at Walmart wherever and um
their big thing was like how do we
manufacture this with no people so
they're like um can we do this where
it's automated and 10 times cheaper than
everybody else and so they claim they
claim that they're factories that have
the robots that produce these have like
no humans on the line uh I don't know if
this is true because like even like
Tesla which tried to do this with the
factors was not able to do this but like
maybe maybe it's true or maybe it's like
pretty much true like there's very
minimal human intervention how did you
find this guy
um someone dm'd it remember I talked
about being known well somebody was like
you're gonna love this this is a perfect
Billy of the week
um I forgot your name and it looks like
him and his brother co-founded it and
their sisters the CEO yeah so it's all
in the family family owned they own the
whole thing I think still and it did
basically they have uh 8 000 employees
26 offices around the world last year
they tripled sales to 1.1 billion
um in 20 in 2021 and uh you know they're
still not as big as Hasbro or Mattel or
like you know Procter Gamble which are
like hasbros 6 billion Mattel's 5
billion pngs like you know 80 billion
um but now they're like launching new
new products and new new brands so so
they do the toy business they conquer
that becomes a billionaire there and
then he's like all right what can we do
next so they go into other products and
now they're like all right we're going
to create um what does Procter and
Gamble do they have products in every
category we're gonna do diapers and so
they go into the diapers thing with this
brand called rascal friends and I think
in the first year the rasculine friends
is going to do 200 million uh that's not
the first year but last year they're
gonna do 200 million this next year
they're projecting it to be 400 million
and so um highly profitable just print
cash and the toy business basically
prints cash they use it to invest in
these so how did the diaper business
take off well they saw that Huggies is
partnered with Disney and Procter
Gamble's partnered with Warner Brothers
that's why they could do like you know
Disney or like Batman like things like
that and so these guys went partner with
Coco melon which is the YouTube like Kid
Sensation and so um Rascal and Friends
uh sorry last year was 100 million this
year 150 million next year projecting
200 million
um then they also did this with hair
care they have a brand called Monday
hair then they did pet food with a brand
called nude they did a collagen brand
called dose and they're just trying to
replicate this with each thing so the
Hair Care brand is going to do 60
million this year and so there's
stacking these on top of each other
but then
the coup de gras the biggest one they're
trying to do of all of them is this
thing called zuru Tech
um so what are they trying to do with
zero Tech they're basically trying to
create a factory that can just build you
houses robots that build houses is the
the big idea and so they're trying to
create the biggest Factory uh on Earth
period uh bigger than Tesla's
gigafactory bigger than all of it
so let me give you the stats on this
thing
um where is it so they're trying to
scale it up to 1.6 million square meters
two kilometers I can't even okay so two
so that's uh that's about a mile and a
quarter long yeah
2000k
yeah and two thousand meters yeah
they're trying to yeah they're trying to
um they're trying to hire 2 000 more
people in the next 24 months which is
just insane and so their idea with this
um
with this Factory for the for the zero
Tech thing it's basically like you can
design a home they basically took a
gaming engine like unreal or like uh
Unity or whatever and they're like okay
if you go into a game like The Sims you
can like create a house and you can
paint the wall and you could put a couch
there and then you could put make the
floors different like in The Sims you
can basically design a house you can
design a whole neighborhood you could
design a large house small house
whatever so they're like why don't we do
that except it's real like when you're
done you click print and then the robots
basically just make that house and so
this is what they're trying to do with
this thing which honestly just sounds
like you know frankly bizarre
um but that's what they're doing and so
that's the that's the new Venture that
they're spinning out of this called zero
Tech and it's basically a way to to use
robots to build homes which is just kind
of insane that is the architecture
software using a gaming engine what do
you think made them so special
I mean this guy like I'm looking at him
and he he just seemed like a have you
ever met any New Zealand guys
yeah like they're like the same like The
Stereotype of like an Australian guy's
like fun-loving loves to get drunk bad
with money will spend all their money
because they're like they just want to
like be care like a lot of Australians
don't have a lot of savings because they
just don't mind spending at the bar
they're fun loving they're always a
blast to be around uh that's and that's
what this guy like if I had to like just
look at him like oh this guy seems like
he goes all in on things well I think
the key he's a redhead key to success so
you know redheads they they have a chip
on their shoulder from day one that
there they got something to prove so I
think that's like a
uh that's a big deal that's I would say
80 for real though another 20 is hard
work
fine this guy's cool and he's only 35 I
think yeah so I'm gonna read you some of
his uh tips for Success okay you can
give me a uh a thumbs up thumbs down or
or a man or whatever you know if it's if
it's just okay so the first one rethink
your vocabulary I never use the word
employee because we're High performing
team and we're playing different
positions I'm coaching the team I'm
trying to get the best players in all
the positions we have team members not
employees in our business what do you
think cool I I do the same thing I I
hate calling them employees sometimes
I'll use the word staff but I hate using
employees uh but yeah I thought you just
say the help
I'll do the same thing also I'll never
like when somebody
um when they say it worked for for you
I'm like no you work with me it does
exactly what I was gonna say I always
correct people on that oh yeah you know
I work for Sean no you don't work for
Sean you work with me and I I never say
I work for anybody I work with them and
it's an arrangement it's a partnership
um I do X and I get Y and you do X you
get Y and that's it um you know hold
yourself to that okay next one bullets
before cannonballs he goes the first
thing I learned one of the things I
learned early on was to fire bullets
before cannonballs we're always firing
lots of little bullets everywhere to see
if those work if they work then we fire
a cannonball behind it
love it that's a good analogy
um all right Break The Rules I went to
University I studied law and commerce
but I didn't like it to like it to be
honest and there was a big hill I had to
walk up every day to get to law school I
didn't like that Hill either I did it
for a year and I thought oh why not have
a CR why not have a crack at just doing
this work thing so I moved to China I
didn't even make it to my second year of
law I missed out which is probably a
good thing a blessing in disguise
okay yeah I don't really get the the uh
it's a move to China but I didn't like a
hill
Different Strokes for different folks
but I appreciate it all right don't be
shaken by competition so he says in the
early days we had this tiny production
lab we spent half our money on an
injection Motor Machine we started to
produce our hot air balloon which didn't
sell many of because it didn't meet
regulations globally so we went online
and copied a couple products one was a
frisbee we got sued after it we went to
a toy fair and we got through day one
but the companies we copied came to our
booth and yelled at us then we started
innovating and it was our journey that
took us six or seven years to get
successful at product we lived off very
very very little we scrapped uh we
scrapped and scraped to find something
that would work
awesome okay yeah right fair enough all
right let me skip these let me see if
there's another good one um okay don't
lose sight he says I remember when we
made our first million hey fan of the
show
um we did we did a big deal with David
Beckham where we made it David Beckham
Tamagotchi at Walmart I was 21 at the
time we got a 28 million dollar order
from Walmart but we couldn't Finance it
Walmart ended up canceling the whole
order we was stuck with half of the
Tamagotchis we were so excited because
it was this because this awful amount of
money at the time we had no money but we
got a little bit complacent we were
always checking how we were doing every
month and we ended up losing I think uh
200 000 that month we lost a bunch of
money we sat down and we thought from
this day forward we are never ever gonna
have a month where we lose money we took
that approach and we never lost money
again we were always profitable this
guy's awesome what's his name Nick
mowbray
yeah mobre I think hey if anyone knows
Nick or can do the introduction to him
this guy I would love to have him on the
Pod this guy's awesome right this guy's
done the redhead Joe
love Reddit
my friend said something really funny he
goes yeah my wife he uh he goes um we're
I'm doing this deal and like uh we were
dealing with some people that I was like
I just can't tell if this person's like
all hype or they're just gonna go like a
charlatan or what and um and I was like
for some reason they're just not getting
along with this other person and I don't
know what to make of it he goes oh he
goes I've seen this many times in
business
two charlatans can't be in a room at the
same time together they just combust
they can't stand it because it's like my
girlfriend she's a redhead she she told
me once I can't stand being in the room
with another redhead and I was like it's
the same thing with charlatans and he
goes
one is a Charlotte one person's a
charlatan you put him in the room with
another known charlatan they'll hate
each other
that's so funny
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
our buddy Julian has this company called
demand curve he's like hey will you
speak at this like Divine curve
conference thing and I'm like you know
you know the rule the rule is hell no we
don't do nothing for nobody except if
it's our friends if we do it for free
right so it's either big money or a big
friend Julian's big friend so I did it
for free the um so we go on there and
I'm like um I don't know what this is oh
it's a it's a it's a conference talk
about audience building or content or
something like that you get that all the
time I know and so you go up there and
you're like I'm gonna do my Spiel but
something really interesting happened so
it was me and this other guy
sauger from the show called breaking
points I bet you're familiar with it
have you heard of this or Ben you have
to know about breaking points you know
this thing no you guys don't know about
this okay this is basically like a like
like a TV show like a podcast you know
The Young Turks that that channel on
YouTube that was like they did I know
breaking points which is I Googled
soccer and Crystal
they do their own version of like a
political correspondence show or
whatever like a I don't even know what
you call a political talk show basically
and they do it they started off just
doing it on YouTube or whatever and
um and it's kind of blown up and so this
he was the guy was on the panel with me
and there was a few things he said that
I was like really taking notes on I was
like oh that's really smart and also
this what this guy's doing is actually
pretty awesome and I think
could get huge like it looks on the
surface
sort of goofy it looks like kids playing
dress-up because it's like they they
made it look like a talk show so they're
like at a desk he wears a suit and tie
um you know so it's like but it's like
you know is it like a liberal news it's
like a liberal uh a Young Turk sing or
is it like conservative uh I don't know
how they would call it I'm not very
political so I don't really even want to
say I want to misclassify it but it's
their schtick is like they um they cover
the things they say the things that the
mainstream media is not covering or is
either undercovering these stories or
they're just like spinning it for their
own agenda and they're like we'll just
try to say the truth like what we think
is and like we'll just call it like we
see it
um which again everybody says but the
question is like how close are you to
actually doing that it's like company
values every company says Integrity is
our core value as they like you know
destroy the Earth and so um and so
that's what these guys do and so they
have this set and it like looks like
you've you went to you know when you go
to like KFC in like China and it's like
I don't know when I do KFC you've even
been somewhere right
I don't know Canada where have you gone
Sam yeah you know like uh on Friday
nights when you're like all right at
Domino's in Tokyo like you know that
feeling
sorry I had to Big Dog you there with my
International experience but uh but yeah
basically they're this like I lived in
China and they had this phrase nqr like
I'd be like yeah I go to McDonald's here
but I don't really like it I don't know
why they're like oh it's nqr well thank
you not quite right and it's the perfect
description which is it's almost exactly
right but it's not quite right and all
my uh all my Asian friends say it's same
same but different
yeah exactly same same but different
like this this knockoff Nike shoe it's
same same just different
exactly so so anyways that's like what
these guys show looks like it looks
almost like a knockoff correspondence
show that's kind of that you know my
initial judgment then they started
watching it and they got on Joe Rogan
and I was like wow this and Joe loves
the show Joe's like Joe basically he was
telling me just now he goes I go how'd
you get on Rogan and he's like Rogan was
just a fan of the show and he just
reached out was like Hey I love the show
guys and they're like wow uh we kind of
didn't think we were like you know we
had like most people like early on you
kind of feel like am I doing the right
thing I quit my job to do this
it's not big huge it's on YouTube
it was on YouTube and how many views an
episode uh they'll have like I don't
know they have like 800 000 subscribers
or something like that so they're gonna
go like media now but this was like
before that Joe got on it well Joe was
like into it when it was pretty early
and he was like they're like wow Joe
Rogan amazing if the number one
podcaster in the world thinks this is
like awesome maybe we're on to something
so they just kept going and then
um Joe invited them on the show and then
there they they've launched like a paid
subscription because they're like hey
look like if you go to their website it
just says help us what is it so breaking
point that kind of what does the the
title say goes
like help us beat uh mainstream Media or
something like that like help us defeat
mainstream Media or like cover the
stories that they don't cover some like
it painted them as an enemy which is
great uh like just a smart smart like
marketing tactic basically
um but but basically they so so Joe uh
their first show the first paid show Joe
Rogan came on and so you know they like
had this like amazing way to like kind
of kick off but that's because they had
put in a few years of like hard work
before that it's like four years old now
and
um and so he said a couple things I
thought were really smart I'm gonna
share them here in fact I actually think
we should just run the whole
uh interview we just did with him like
as a my first million episode if those
guys were down to that because I thought
there's a bunch of interesting things
one thing he go they go how did you get
started like what's how did you get your
first thousand customers and or like
subscribers or whatever
and we all get asked this a bunch I
rarely do you hear something that
interesting but he said a pretty
interesting answer he goes well here's
what I did
I saw that in my Niche there were these
people that were already like popular
accounts and so he's like I just went
and looked at who are the top one
percent of of like popular accounts
already
and then I just decided okay the first
content I create is just going to be
content that they love because if they
love it they'll share it they'll kind of
endorse it and that'll drive a bunch of
growth right away of the Right audience
and so what he did was he's like okay
they have this they need data they need
visualizations they need charts cool so
I'm just gonna or they need transcripts
like quick transcripts of like what
Trump just said they need to have like
the edited well-formatted transcript so
he's like we weren't doing our own
opinions and Analysis no I would just
sit there and I would live when Trump
was talking I'm transcribing it I clean
it up I format it I have the first to
post Trump said this and then those guys
would retweet it he's like and that's
how I got my first like 10 000
subscribers he's like after you get 10
000 they're psychologically the same
where you'll just start growing faster
because people want to follow popular
accounts What It Is Well what was your
advice though to these people on growing
an audience
um my advice was pretty simple I go I
don't think you should grow an audience
for the sake of growing an audience like
um the audience is basically a byproduct
of you doing something else you really
want to do like if you just got that
itch you want to scratch like I want to
create content like I've seen YouTubers
I think I could do it that's actually a
better reason to go do it than
if I can get to a million subscribers
then I'll upsell my merch to this
percentage of them and I could make this
much money it's like don't do the
calculating way to do it just be like
I'm doing this because either like in my
case it was I'm super curious about
these topics and like how am I going to
justify spending nine hours reading
about this [__] topic that like I
have no agenda for well if I had a
podcast or a YouTube channel then I
could just like make the content out of
that then it has like a kind of like a
purpose to my curiosity I have like an
end point to it I have a justification
for my curiosity I get to be
professionally curious or like lately
when I when I originally started the Pod
I literally wrote this in a doc I've
shared this before I wrote most likely
nobody's going to listen to this but
there's a hack
really smart and interesting successful
people are willing to go on a podcast
even if it has they don't know how many
listeners it has and so at the very like
my main goal is to just have an excuse
to meet with 50 awesome people that live
in San Francisco like I'm in the tech
Hub of the uni of the World San
Francisco
and I don't drink coffee so I don't want
to just invite these guys to coffee I'll
invite them on my podcast instead that
was my whole like number one success
criteria like number one agenda with
like starting this podcast was oh it's a
great excuse to hang out with these
people that are like they're nearby
they're in my Orbit and don't do it and
like I don't know it's better than
saying let me just get lunch with you
please please please and so that was why
I started the Pod dude I have uh like
people ask me all the time as well how
to build an audience and I used to have
like an somewhat academic answer where
I'm like well you just kind of like find
content that like ranks well other
places and you repurpose do all this
this and lately I just like quit saying
that and I just go well just like be an
interesting person live an interesting
life and just be at least kind of okay
at talking about it publicly uh right
because the thing you just said like if
you're interesting if you lead an
interesting life then all you have to do
is share 10 of it and you only have to
be okay at talking about it give people
a peek into 10 of your life
yeah and you don't even need to be that
great and so people like over optimize
for like this like the like you know
it's kind of like when people talk about
search they're like well you need all
those keywords and do this do this and
I'm like or I just do dope [__] and
write about it and people just gonna go
straight to the website and look it up
and that's harder and uh I still think
you need that other stuff but like I I
still think that it's mostly a game of
just be interesting learn interesting
stuff and be kind of good at talking
about it so everyone else can consume
and like there are people that do it
other ways like Trung who used to work
for you at the hustle you kind of
discovered him you set up I think his
Twitter account now he's got like
whatever I don't know a million Twitter
followers something crazy
and I don't think Trung took that advice
like I don't think Trung lives a
interesting life or has this interesting
business experience that's what he's
sharing well he's he he learns about
interesting he but yes that is true and
so he didn't exactly you could make he's
a remix right you could make the
argument yeah but you could also make
the argument that he's leaving leading
an interesting life in that he's
learning and discovering cool stuff uh
so that's like you could make the
argument both ways but I remember I'm
not I I hate saying this because I'm
definitely not like a ladies man but
I've come a long way from being like a
Napoleon Dynamite like males man yeah
more of a malesman
I'm a guys guy but not the way that you
think it is not the way that it's
usually meant like our many guys's guy
and uh
but I've come a long way from looking
like Napoleon Dynamite and I remember
like I had some like 18 year old ask me
about like meeting girls and I was like
shocked I was like your your bar for
advice is quite low here but let me give
you some advice if I could give anything
which was basically I'm like you'll meet
more women if you just focus on yourself
and have cool badass hobbies and just
invite people to come and do those
Hobbies with you and I was like that's
the that's the coolest hack ever for a
young man you just do dope [__] and then
you just bring along people that's kind
of like that with content
yeah that's exactly right I think there
are a bunch of different ways to win you
could be uh like Ben for how to take
over the world I would say he's curious
about these you know great men in
history or like these you know these
sort of like biographies or whatever and
then what he does he does a service he
says I'll save you time so I call him a
Time Saver because he packages it down
into something concise the hustles
newsletter and milk roads newsletter is
exactly that it's a Time Saver
I said what do you do you curate you
package you deliver then you have like
you know sort of like a remixer a
remixer basically takes maybe one or two
unrelated things spins them together
puts them together and and puts that out
there
you have an original content creator
that's like a naval or apology they're
coming up with like independent Theses
about the world and opinions and
analyzes that really just originate from
them and they put that out in the world
um and then you have what I'll call like
a lifestyle influencer that's what
you're talking about which was lead an
interesting Life share 10 of it so
there's all these different play styles
that you can use it's like in a video
game so you want to play tank you want
to play DPS you want to play healer you
can play all these different roles and
they'll all they're all winning you just
have to know which play style you're
trying to play uh so I see that with
with content
um but the one use you recommended which
is live an interesting life and then
share 10 of it I think that that is the
most fun play style to play and the most
valuable
and the most valuable and the most
unique because anybody honestly I don't
know offense they're trying but like
many people do and anybody can
go read [__] Reddit and Wikipedia and
like create a threat of you know here's
the story of how whatever the dude
created Starbucks and it's like okay the
one that you repeatedly done is is the
hot sauce Guy what's the hot sauce guy
okay yeah everyone talks about that guy
that guy is the king of the thread boys
yes
every thread boy at home has like a
small bottle of sriracha on a shrine and
they're like I'll always remember the
day I could tell people that Sriracha
started in Thailand
or the peppers were so bad that the
Neighbors at the factory hated him and
they don't even advertise and it's the
same bottle since day one
hot dog is still a dollar and fifty
cents
like you know classical but uh the one
you said was the most I think the most
rewarding playstyle and
um my trainer had a great phrase for
this because I was like
um I was asking about his business I was
like I was trying to help him with his
business and he ended up dropping like
like I thought I'm I'm the business guy
I'm gonna share with him this great
knowledge and I was like you got to
think about your Niche your audience
who's your ID you know who's your
customer Persona and I was like just
looking back you know just cringe City
about like trying to help him with these
things and he just said I was like you
don't have a website you don't have a
business card blah blah and he just go
and I was like so who's your you know
you got to know who's your customer he
goes my customers are people that love
what I do and I was like I was like okay
that sounds like some smooth ass r b
lyric but what does that mean what are
you gonna do with that he's like and I
didn't understand at that time but he
just he's like that's it he's like my
customers are going to be the people
that love what I do and I said okay well
what do you do he's like I'll train you
on your Fitness and during that during
that session I'll train your mind as
much as your body right it's mindset and
because the mindset's totally aligned
with this stuff and that's what I'm into
and I'll just share with you stuff that
I'm doing with my own training with my
own mindset training or my personal
training I'll work out with you together
sometimes and I'll come to your house
and we'll just kick it for hours I don't
I don't watch the clock right like
that's how I want to live and people my
customers are going to be people who
want that
and I'm not going to try to go backwards
and say what does the market want I'm
going to conform myself to it and so
there was this real artist streak to it
I thought all right well that sounds
cool but like that [__] don't work in
the real world sure enough how does it
work
I was this only client I think at the
time and he and we work out like in my
garage but we just leave the garage open
and then people walk by and they walk by
and he never he never he just super
friendly with him but never says like
hey by the way you know if you're ever
interested in my services here's my card
never like they would walk by he would
joke around with them sort of like just
a flirt with people and then he would
just like you know go back and keep
doing our thing he's just a happy guy
by like the seventh day people are like
man it looks like y'all are having fun
the music looks fun the home gym they
saw us like setting it up each day it
would get better and they saw us joking
around they would see my you know I'm
breaking a sweat they would see how
we're using like we'd use our tree and
we'd use all this stuff that was just
around us because I didn't have all this
equipment and it just looked like two
people having a lot of fun and so my
neighbor signed just a bunch of there's
a bunch of sweaty shirtless guys hugging
you know what I mean hanging off the
trees and just yeah his body and so
guess what people wanted some of that
and so my neighbor signed up and her
husband signs up then the other neighbor
signs up then my sister's visiting she
does a workout she signs up my mom signs
up my brother-in-law signs up she their
niece my niece and nephew sign up
everybody starts signing up this guy now
is a full roster still never had a
website never had a business card uh
never went and knocked on a door tried
to do a sales pitch all these people
like confluenced their schedules to him
he's not even a trainer he's just a guy
who just comes in and hangs out dog the
best part is he's me
[Laughter]
you need a guy to come hang out with you
I got a guy long story short this phrase
of who are my customers the people that
love what I do that is like playing in
my opinion business at the highest level
because it is the most freeing imagine
if that was true that's the most freeing
thing you could do right same thing with
content creation Who Am I who am I going
to get subscribers how am I going to
grow my audience I'm just gonna do the
most interesting things I'm gonna share
it as I go and the people who follow me
gonna be the people who love what I do
and like that is just I think a much
better way to go than like this frankly
a sort of desperate approach that I
think most people take to building a
business or getting customers getting
subscribers all that stuff dude let me
show you an example of I think might be
the exact opposite of what we're talking
about so I've been researching and I
think someone's DMV on this on Twitter
but I found this thing called strong
land like the word strong and then the
word land strong land publishing his
main thing is called uh life math money
all right check this out
so this guy he owns maybe half a dozen
to a dozen I've I've found like four or
five so far uh different Twitter handles
one is is called the 48 Laws of Power
bot or quote bot I believe another one
is called the book of pook p-o-o-k and
the 48 Laws of Power bot quote or quote
bot is just like he's got a ton of
quotes loaded into this and it has maybe
two or three hundred thousand followers
another one is called the book of pook I
think that's how you pronounce puke
p-o-o-k and he's just like quoting like
this pickup artist from the early 2000s
that no longer writes and then he owns a
handful of more of these like just
Twitter handles that are just like
generic and they're all basically
focused for men and it's about getting
laid meeting girls making money getting
fit and he owns like six or twelve of
these handles which is obviously like
not the hardest thing to grow because
it's like these cool taboo topics so
like it's one of those things where you
don't talk about your friends but
everyone wants to be better at all those
things so you follow these these guys
and he like has like a circular thing
where he like retweets each one and each
handle
links off to a gumroad page that sells a
document related to that so like the 48
law is a power one it's like here's how
you get more powerful and power here's
how you get more power and influence at
your job which like who doesn't want to
learn that and he sells it for 89 and
then it's another one it's like here's a
bunch of lines to pick up girls here's
like a workout plan to get abs in eight
weeks or here's like the perfect way to
eat healthy and feel good and if I had
to guess I would say that he's doing
between 500 and a million dollars a year
in sales just off these Gum Road things
because you can see the sales so
basically uh not the sales the reviews I
think no no it's a sale so like for
example oh wow live intentionally 90 day
self-improvement program it's I think it
costs 89 and it says 9506 sales how much
is that is that 900 that's half a
million that's half a million bucks uh I
don't know how long right so maybe this
has been out for years I think he's only
been doing it for two years
and then there's like you know his
crypto one there's his like uh uh you
know build your Twitter audience and how
much is that how many how many did that
sell so that has five thousand four
hundred uh sales so oh how much dollars
uh let's see I want like 100 bucks how
much is it 179 so
golly for his Twitter one has generated
a million dollars his next one has
generated 500 000 so I think pretty safe
to say he's doing at least half a
million a year probably closer to a
million
is that funny is this is this hilarious
this little guy and his name is Harsh
strongman I believe his name is so it's
like an anonymous name and his blog is
called
lifemathmoney.com and if you go to and
look up who is Harsh strongman and he
says I'm a fine certified financial
planner in India and I guess he he just
has this blog and he talks about this
stuff and and I think it's cool I think
there's this Anonymous blogger who only
uses a some type of like freeish looking
website builder and uh gumroad it's just
killing it and I think it's awesome
that's amazing that is this is hilarious
it's awesome right when I think about a
horse strong man a man who just embodies
life math and money I think of an Indian
a mid-20s independent Indian certified
financial planner
like
you know this is my cousin Vikram I just
found out
are living there's a reason Alpha and
accountant both start with a
this guy's as Alphas they can get the
alpha accountant is gonna be his new
thing and he's gonna have it he's gonna
have a Twitter and on like Excel courses
your [__] yeah
that's hilarious the Andrew Tate of
excel
all right
um dude I uh on air I need you to help
me make a decision all right okay so I
am in the process of I'm I stopped in St
Louis so I'm recording this from St
Louis but I'm driving from New York to
Austin I always stop in St Louis for
five days to see family I'm gonna drive
back to Austin
I miss New York I miss Brooklyn already
I absolutely you missed the energy
there's something about this city
the city
you have to go romantic New York for
some reason that's why I refuse to go
there
[Laughter]
I love it I like I'm in Grind Mode I
love being there but there's one thing
that I'm currently doing that is it's it
is something that I told myself I'm not
gonna do it and that is [__] about
taxes and let taxes decide where I live
I'm 100 doing that right now so I want
to tell you some numbers
so uh I currently live in Texas which
has no state income I think the federal
what what's the federal uh tax uh tax
rate for the highest income is what's it
36 or 37 36 ish yeah all right so I
think it's a little above 30 36 so
hypothetically on a million dollars of
income I'm spending three hundred and
seventy thousand dollars a year on taxes
or around 30
31 yeah Federal because Texas doesn't
have income so Thirty one thousand
dollars a month in tax uh sorry uh
Thirty one thousand a month yeah which
adds up to about 30 uh 370 a year in New
York if I move there I would basically
be giving away 51 to 52 of my income
because uh the city of New York has like
a 3.8 tax rate and then the state of New
York has a 9.7 tax rate and so that
means I'm I would have to be spending an
additional 11 500 a month in income
taxes plus New York rent that's the New
York State rent that's not even the
digital event of your place yeah yes
plus the torrent of a place my current
mortgage right now in Austin is around
four thousand to five thousand dollars a
month I would not want to purchase a
place in Brooklyn I would want to rent a
place and my budget to renting to have a
family there would be around nine
thousand to to fourteen thousand dollars
a month in rent probably thirteen
probably probably 11 to 12 I could
probably get a place that I would want
and that's what I would spend so I would
be spending just and then let's say my
income this is all hypothetical I'm not
saying what I do or don't make if my
income is two million I'm going to be
spending around 280 000 a year in extra
income taxes plus an additional hundred
and fifty thousand dollars a year in uh
rent meaning my costs are gonna be like
400 to 500 000 a year in additional
costs just to live there not including
the fact that like I'm in St Louis right
now I just went out to eat for three
people it's 51 if I'm in New York for
three people for breakfast it's gonna be
you know like Yeah a hundred bucks two
times the cost so how would you justify
making the move or not move
well I kind of did myself right because
I live in California and California has
the same problems that New York has a
High Cost of Living High state tax that
sort of deal and now and I you know I
work remote I could live anywhere at
this point
um
and so you know it's very tempting
especially when you hear like you meet
people who who live in Texas then you
meet people who live in Puerto Rico
they're like you pay federal 37 I pay
four percent I pay zero percent on
capital gains like wow
um all right I guess that's also an
option so there's sort of like no end to
it and I I used to live in Indonesia and
um you know for two grand a month or
three grand a month like you know you're
living large
um out there so like you know you could
have a I had a cook and a maid that
lived in my house I had a driver that
drove me everywhere and like you know
didn't have to think about anything so
there really is no end to this idea of
like optimizing cost of living uh versus
you know like what you want to do there
is no end to it but maybe there are
thresholds yeah there's there's more
rungs to the latter than even what you
presented as I guess what I'm trying to
say you could do you can take it even
further
um I think that
I've always thought that sort of like
goes back to that what you know what
advice would my 18 year old self give me
my 18 year old self which was like a
more simple-minded version of myself
would say this doesn't mean they're
right but they would say this
wait I thought you're rich
like oh you wait you're wait so you're
moving to where you don't want to live
to save money that sounds not very rich
right so if it's the same if if it's all
the same in terms of where you enjoy
living cool then obviously pick that
pick the difference
if you enjoy one more I would go to it
now it's the hard part is how do you
price that enjoyment how do you price
that energy of New York
we're gonna put a dollar we're gonna
price it we're gonna say it's around
four or five hundred thousand but dude
for the same price I can live in Texas
six months and in New York six months
and fly private back and forth twice
actually like two round trips and it'd
still be cheaper uh but that's yeah but
it would also add hassle to your life
right so there's there's some situations
where the variety adds what you want
right it's like a win-win it's like oh
yeah I don't want to be in one place all
year anyways or I like the weather this
time of year in one place and this time
in another place so I'm just gonna move
around the weather and that happens to
coincide well with my tax situation but
basically my thoughts my simple thought
process is this if you're rich you can
do tax optimizations but make sure it's
not driving the car right so it gets to
be in the car but it doesn't drive the
car so I would do some things that are
no sweat that are going to save you tax
money oh great I would do that I would
not move which is like one of the
biggest things that changes your like
day-to-day quality of life I would not
move to a different place just like
based on taxes as the primary reason I
would have to have another primary
reason so for example my reason for
being in California is that me and my
wife's family is all here and I just
want to see them more often and have
that be like I prefer that lifestyle I
don't know how many years we all have
left we're all healthy or my kids are
little and they get to have this
experience with their grandparents
around but that matters more to me than
than anything on the tax side so that's
my decisive reason I made that one
reason the priority and then I'll live
with the rest so I think that's what you
should do you should come up with your
one decisive reason about where you're
going to live and I would guess if
you're rich that reason should not be
taxes
I gotta do it unfortunately but golly it
sucks in the back of my head it's that
famous Michael Jordan quote
[Laughter]
Republicans buy shoes too
worthy quote
Yeah but but also you know you also got
to factor in how much more are you going
to make how much more is maybe the
connections you'll make in New York one
investment you make
um you know you can make more uh it's
easier to make more uh for a guy like uh
guys like us than it is to um adjust
your lifestyle to try to save more I
find it
I would rather work harder to make more
money than change my lifestyle in a way
that I feel like I'm I'm making some
compromise in order to save money
well I think I'm gonna do it I if I
could do this again for some reason I
think Miami is just like hell on Earth
uh it's not for some reason I could name
about 50 reasons why I think that I
think Miami's horrible but at the same
time if I could do it again I almost
wish I would have done so right now I
live in Austin Texas it's because I got
a bunch of friends there my best friends
are there and we had an officer if I
could have done it again I would have
done Florida though and New York because
Texas doesn't have nice enough weather
that I'm just going just for the weather
during winter time whereas Florida like
you know you could I feel like I'm in
the Caribbean sometimes in certain parts
of it I wish I would have done Florida
and New York if I could do it again
that's what I wish I would have done
I'm surprised the best friends being in
Austin thing is not a bigger pool for
you I feel like that's huge it is and
that's why I'm I'm I don't actually mean
if I could do it again I wish the Stars
would have aligned so that could have
happened it's kind of what I mean what a
slap in the face I'm just glad I'm not
your friend I'm not Neville who lives
right next door to you in Austin who's
like oh the energy in New York that's
what's gonna get you you're gonna move
away from me for the the energy come on
bro
dude New York's happening man it is
quite fun it is fun whenever I walk
around there I get pumped I do get
pumped uh but I also like also I also
want to kill like I I want to kill
someone half the time dude like every
time I'm in line at Whole Foods or some
grocery store there I see a fight is
this there's always a Como there's
always commotions it's all something's
always happening it always raises my
blood pressure and I want to like I get
in my protector mode that's hilarious
um all right what else we got wanna do
some more yeah uh I have one thing uh so
I think we've talked about this and
we've just you and I have hired this guy
but go to dreamstudiocourse.com
his name's Kevin Shen and I went and
looked at his landing page this guy's
landing page for a course a is awesome
and B he's selling a course that I never
in a million years would have thought
would work but then I look at it and I
think 100 you've nailed it and I
understand how you could potentially
make a million dollars a year so it's
called dream Studio course and it's a
fifteen hundred dollar course I don't
know why he didn't just go two thousand
but it's a fifteen hundred dollar course
all on setting up your your Zoom setup
basically because I don't even think
it's for a podcaster but crazy cool
looking landing page and whenever I when
I saw his landing page I thought wow I
really want this uh but how sick is that
landing page it's a great landing it's a
great landing page for a bunch of
different reasons like first just start
with headlines so headline is not a
course about uh setting up your Zoom it
says make your home video setup look
like Hollywood right dream outcome so
sells the dream outcome right away then
there's a picture of him that's you know
that shows a really awesome video setup
so you know show don't tell and then it
basically says build your studio with
expert help it's a six week course
that'll do whatever
um okay enroll here so good call to
action and then he's got a bunch of
before and afters right here's Thiago
Forte look he looked like [__] before
now he looks great right
um you know look here's this person now
they look great and he just keeps
showing you know basically success
stories of Transformations because
fundamentally when people buy a course
they're buying transformation of some
kind they want to walk in one way and
walk out another and uh most courses
I've struggled with this myself most
courses struggle to even understand that
you're selling change you're selling a
transformation not content not
information and secondly they don't know
how to show that I can actually provide
this for you and with something that
like the visual like this you're gonna
get a before and after which is like
before and after is my favorite sales
pitch of all time
um I think a before and after is the
most compelling sales pitch do you have
like a file or something that because
all you're you're saying this as if you
have like like categories of headlines
headlines or of uh well you're like uh
you're like oh he's doing the before and
after style headline I love that style
yeah I have the and so in my course I
teach these I'm like here's a bunch of
frames you can use to like sell your
product if you can do did you send that
to me like this yeah I will like this
yeah you use before and after if it's
not visual there's another one I call
stop the struggle so stop the struggle
you sent me this landing page actually
abstract Ops used to have this landing
page uh I think you invest in those guys
they it was like a stick figure running
away from a tornado and it just said
stop putting off your back office tax
your back back office tasks or like stop
running away from your your your to-do
list or whatever and that's what I call
a stop the struggle pitch which is
basically saying instead of saying what
we do for you we'll say we can put you
out of your pain is that pain hurting
you I can stop the pain for you I can
stop the struggle that you're having
right he could do the same thing so he
does dream outcome before and after
right like make your home video setup
look like Hollywood he could also have a
stop the struggle which is like
um you know uh you know basically a stop
showing up to work looking like this and
it's like the up the nose camera shot
blah blah and it's like instead you
could look like this after and so you
know so basically I have these different
frames and I'm like this is a way that
you can present your product your
information and so because I have a one
of my sessions in my course is a landing
page one and so that's why I'm like you
this is where you need to use this it's
on your landing page because your
landing page is your 24 7 salesman that
will always deliver the pitch exactly as
they were trained to do 24 7 anywhere in
the world never have a sick day and take
no commission on sales and so like a
landing page is the greatest salesman
ever and so I think you should train
your salesman to like be able to sell
your product effectively essentially I
uh I'm writing a new landing page now
um for my thing and it is daunting like
it no matter how many landing pages I've
written it is always hard well because
your order keeps going up because you're
like oh I know what Great Looks like I
know I want it to be great and so what
would have otherwise been sufficient
five years ago now you look at that
you're like no I'm sure it can be better
I know it could be better right because
you're already really you're really good
if I was gonna get somebody in my
landing page I would hire you and so
you're already very good at it
um so the fact that you're feeling
daunted is like I don't know like a
musician going back into the studio to
record their new album and it's like
they know that they're good but it's
like I gotta do it again I gotta make
magic again I gotta make a hit again
that's exactly how I feel I'm staring at
this landing page and I'm like no this
is lame this isn't up to my standard
this sucks this sucks and I'm just like
looking for you know what I what I
usually do is what I like to do is find
the way that I've been getting
inspiration now is I find uh competitors
that exist now or that used to offer a
similar service and I go to uh
newspapers.com and I find old articles
written about them and I see how
reporters used to explain this and if I
see a catchy sentence I go boom got it
um I'm still in that angle and so that's
what I that's how I've been using uh
that's how I've been getting inspiration
is I just use newspapers.com to find old
just articles New York Times written
about a certain company that's in the
same space
there was this guy we hired once and I
actually don't think it was a smart hire
I made a bunch of mistakes now I think
about looking back at my business career
I'm like man we hired a firm to do that
like yeah we hired this person to do
this we paid this like I remember out of
the Indy 500s like was doing their race
or whatever and it was like Hey you
there's free billboard space we can give
it to you for your app
and then I was like oh wow that's cool
Indy 500 I've heard of that they're
giving us free space and I we spent the
next 48 hours like filming this [__]
video that was gonna go on this
billboard or this like video billboard
and I was like looking back I'm like oh
my God I how cheap was my attention that
I let this random cold email divert me
and my marketing teams like Focus for 48
hours to do what like did we really
think this billboard was going to like
Indy 500. Drive downloads it was up to
your app so yeah it was on point but
like they're just not trying to download
apps in that moment and like there's no
way to track it it was it was awful and
so like and that's happened to me a
thousand times I've made a thousand dumb
decisions like that I'm like wow we
really like
spent time and energy doing that that's
like kind of embarrassing now that I
know what I know now
um so similarly we had hired a naming
agency
like I hired an agency I don't think
that's a horrible idea I don't think
that's the worst idea I think it was 15
or 25 Grand it was a lot of money and
um it took like six weeks which is also
more expensive it's like if you just had
the name we would have just moved faster
um what was the name that they came up
with
dating app
is that like they just came back with
like Jersey Shore characters your app is
called the situation so we were thinking
so fun
party at the front yeah
so so basically again Pauly D say it
with me Paulie D the latest and greatest
dating
it was like um so anyways it wasn't even
that they did a bad job they actually
did a good job with their thing but it
was just unnecessary it was an
unnecessary thing to do but I I do
respect the craft because I remember I
went to this to the to the meeting room
it's got Eli was sitting there uh I
think Eli Altman is his name I think
um and he was like okay so tell me about
it and I was like so here's the
screenshot and he's like no no just like
tell me about it I'm like so it's an app
that lets you do this it has these
features he's like no no like why'd you
make that and it's like oh because I'm
at the time I was saying I was like so
I'm single I've used dating apps and
and he's like
um I was like they just they all sucked
and so that's why we wanted to make this
great one and I like I was kept rushing
into the here's my answer here's my
solution he's like but like you said it
sucked what sucked like uh what sucked
about him I was like well they're just
like too hard to use again generic and
he's like
so like what did you like do you
remember just getting really frustrated
about it one time so he's asking me
these good questions to like actually
unfold the unpack the customer Stories
the words the phrases that actually mean
something he got beyond the jargon and
then I was like okay so what happens now
now you guys you have this crazy
brainstorming exercise where you come up
with the name he's like no just like
give me some time and he just took a
whiteboard marker and he just sat down
cross-legged like you know like Indian
style in front of a whiteboard on the
floor
and I was like
yeah he's literally like a child at play
and he like he just like put his phone
at silent and put it outside and I was
like whoa
this guy there's no bigger sign of
seriousness than somebody who turns
their phone off it like leaves it
outside of the room and he's like he
just started writing and he started
writing long form like not I was like oh
he's got some names and I went there to
look for names he's no he was like
you know dating is
like hard actually it's not hard it's
just kind of
it's frustrating well the thing that's
frustrating about it is like I know that
I'm a good catch but I'm sitting here
trying to perform and he's just like
writing out like the feelings that go
through the mind of the person the way
the story needs Ed is it's the most like
weirdest horrible thing like he's this
thoughtful thing and he comes up with
like dick butt like
basically
that's basically it
um so he you know so he he did this long
process and I actually think that
there's a um
there's some military phrase which is
like um slow is smooth and smooth is
fast yeah and I've always tried to go
fast when it comes to business stuff how
do I go faster how do we speed this up
and I paid the price many times where
like if I had just slowed down at the on
the appropriate step the whole thing
would have gone faster even though that
step would have gone slower for example
figuring out what is the actual problem
I'm solving what are the what is the
pain that the person is feeling here
what are the words that they would use
to describe it that they that would
resonate with them and get them to nod
their head and be like yeah I've had
that
um
and then how would I explain it in a way
that's simple to them like that's what
he was ultimately trying to do he was
trying to figure out what's the problem
what are the words that somebody would
actually use that would resonate with
them or they nod and be like you know
amen preach like I I feel that you wow
you just you put it in words better than
I even could how I was feeling about
this situation and then oh you described
the solution but instead of describing
in terms of like the features and the
widgets and the gadgets around it like
you tell me kind of like how my life's
gonna be different because I'm using
this and this works this different way
and it kind of makes sense that it would
work that way right because you know
let's use an analogy imagine you ran a
lemonade standing blah blah blah and so
that's what he did and I remember just
walking out of that being like wow
that was like an impressive thing this
guy did and it looked so unimpressive he
asked me some questions he kept slowing
me down didn't want to jump to an answer
then he just sat with a marker alone in
a room and wrote for a long time on this
whiteboard like paragraphs of stuff and
then through that he came out with like
you know a b a better understanding
about my product than I had to begin
with and I think that that like there's
something cool about that process and
like yeah
when you go make this landing page it's
like that's the thing you actually want
to do because slowed smooth and smooth
as fast well did you uh did I show you
that I hired a branding agency
I saw that yeah you sent me this I think
I spent 15 grand on it and they're based
they're in Hong Kong so like I think
there was a like I think normally this
would cost 30 Grand in America and I was
actually happy with the work and this is
normally something I would never do and
it took him 30 days and it's like you
just get this deck that like outlines
and like I never would have done that
and
I think it was totally worth it this is
not something I ever would have done and
I think it was totally because whenever
you like build [__] and you make a
website you slowly iterate and then like
you hire new people and you're and they
like come up with ideas and you're like
no we already tried that or like no that
doesn't work because this page looks
like this like it's I'm like let's just
get it all do it all the right way the
first time and that's something I never
in a million years would have done and
it was worth it
yeah we did that for the milk road too
we hired uh this guy Jeremy
um who did our initial branding and I
never hired a branding agency like that
for for a startup that I was doing but I
was like all right I told Ben I said
we're not going to do it off the bat
like you're saying you're doing it up
front
um I think that's okay I don't think
that's necessarily bad but I also don't
think it's necessary and so usually for
a startup you just kind of want to do it
when I say
off the bat I already had a quarter of a
million in Revenue yeah yeah exactly so
I had told Ben I said he's like uh he
made a logo like in five minutes on
canva and I was like all right I like
this I like the name milk Road sounds
fun goofy easy to say you see I can get
the domain for two thousand dollars
let's do it and he made this logo in
like Fiverr or canva or something like
that and I was like all right
um let's run with it he's like you know
don't you think we should uh blah blah
blah and I was like all right here's the
deal
um it seems like you want to spend more
Cycles on it because you think the brand
is important and I agree the brand will
be important I just don't think it's
important for us to get our first 10 000
subscribers or even 100 000 subscribers
so let's make a deal if we can get to
100 000 subscribers through our janky
thing that will will reward ourselves by
investing in the brand because I think
ultimately the brand this whole exercise
of like having a Cool brand is really
for our own Pride more so than it's
gonna improve the like conversion of
this right now or like it's unproven how
that's going to do so let's let's reward
herself so we got to 100 000 and then we
hired this guy and then he took us
through these like cycles and you know
like
you know review after review of these
like decks and then both were good
I have this guy in India who's like my
designer for all my projects and uh to
create that Milkman character who I
think is actually the best part of the
brand
um
he actually made it this guy in India
made it in like one day and well I was
like wow perfect thank you uh that's
exactly what I wanted uh thank you so
much and so we just like ran with that
dude I think uh I think the outcome was
actually quite good I loved your brand
um
uh no I thought it was good I thought it
was a win I told you the story right
when I went on vacation to Hawaii and
the the uh got Jeremy he lives there he
lives in in Hawaii and he's like oh
you're here like let's hang out I was
like oh yeah great and so he comes to
the hotel
he walks up Barefoot and I was like uh
something happened
okay and he's like um
he said what do you mean I was like
you're not wearing shoes dude and he's
like oh I don't wear shoes
I was like you don't wear shoes and I
was like most [__] branding agency
thing I've ever heard the most creative
is he a white guy respect for taking the
I'm a creative to the the the the peak
like you thought the bean bags in the
office was it you thought that you know
having these like is he like a white guy
who moved to Hawaii or is he born like I
moved away Australian guy I moved to
Hawaii when they moved there they were
like oh we don't need shoes on the
island like we just live we're part of
the island and so they put their shoes
in storage and so he's like yeah we had
to go travel to Australia to go visit
our family he's like I need to go get my
shoes out of storage and I was like what
a weirdo you don't need shoes that much
that you didn't even just Chuck it in
the garage like just in case like you
you put them far away like that's the
equivalent of the guy The Branding
agency guy putting his phone on turning
it off and leaving it outside dude just
just so for the record I'm on board with
that I think trees are stupid I walk
around barefooted all the time when it
gets above if it's 80 above 85 no shirt
no shoes just that's that's just the
rule I'm always outside shirt like I'm
wearing socks right now
no man I you got to get the calluses on
there and then you then you it's like
you wearing shoes anyway
I dig it
um
but I'm happy you're back we went I went
oh I had Ryan holiday on and uh we'll do
a recap about that and then yeah I leave
for one day you guys do a podcast about
how great Hitler is I was like wow all
right
basically we did this part on hit on
Hitler and I was talking about how sad
it was and then our freaking YouTube guy
I he like put up this stupid thumbnail
and it said like
um things or no uh uh things that I
learned from things something about like
it was about like like you know things
you could learn from Hitler on business
building and I was like whoa no not a
chance and I texted bad I go bed you
gotta get rid of this this is that's not
at all what we talked about this is you
know I and it had my face on it it had
my face next to it and I was like dude
that's not even remotely what we talked
about we talked about how horrible he
was
um and so yeah we talked about Hitler
and had Ryan holiday on Justin right
when you left
yeah so I decided to come back
I cut my emergency short to come back
oh I got [__] man I can't let you
totally throw our YouTube guy under the
bus because he did contact me he was
like hey I think I'm gonna do the Hitler
angle I think it'll get tons of clicks
but obviously it'll be controversial do
you think that's cool and I was like
yeah man go for it anything for clicks
more YouTube if you're like and you're
like yeah
saw it while you're at it
not my face only Samsung can you
brighten the image can you break this
face up a little bit
turn down the color balance yeah can you
get damn doing like a heart shape with
his hands
it was the worst man I saw that picture
and I was like Baron I can't have this
man you got to delete it immediately
please delete that this is uh the reason
I thought it was okay is because in the
first 30 seconds of the video you say
Hitler's obviously a bad person but I
don't think it's wrong to like study his
life and learn lessons from it and so I
was like why he says he's a bad person
in the first eight seconds of the video
I think it's okay uh you ever heard that
phrase if you're explaining you're
losing yeah if you're explaining you're
losing that is that that is totally
right I was like it did it didn't work
that that was a that was a I understand
people like that episode but multiple
people were like my favorite episode uh
you know I just shared it I don't know
if you saw those tweets there was a
bunch of people who really liked that
episode
yeah and they also like the Ryan holiday
one so basically uh you're welcome
you're welcome for uh for carrying the
load for a while I'm gonna take a uh
this November I'm thinking about doing a
motorcycle trip and I'll be gone for uh
five days so you're gonna have to see if
you can uh uh I got you carry yeah
you're gonna see if you can carry the
weight during that time
yeah why um
you know why uh yeah
why Stalin is so misunderstood
we could talk about this another time
but do you know that YouTube channel
Ghost Town living
yeah that's um
that abandoned town and they they kind
of Vlog about you know as it as they've
been building it out or whatever so I
invested in it and um it's like me and
Ryan Nathan Barry and like three or four
other guys and I wrote a I think I gave
him 25 Grand so I think I own like less
than one percent of it but uh uh I'm
gonna I want to ride a motorcycle there
and check it out it's like four hours
outside of La I think it'd be fun
that's interesting why do you invest in
that well you can ride your motorcycle
there anyways right so what what do you
think like this is going to become a
valuable investment or no it was an
emotional thing no it's it's it was an
emotional thing my justification was it
was like me Ryan Brent the guy on there
my friend Brendan uh in like three and
Nathan Barry and like and then only
three other entrepreneurs so it was
seven of us and I figure well if I can
like somehow like get invited to like a
thing there or get to talk to them and I
invested 25 Grand I bet I can make that
money back just off these relationships
or just like a cool story like so that's
kind of how I thought about it and I
thought and I asked Nathan well and so I
did for that reason and I also I did the
whole deal without seeing any documents
and just talking to Nathan Nathan Berry
wrote me a text he goes just so you know
there's a little bit of room if you want
to join this here's the pros and here's
the cons here's why I did it and uh he
and I go okay cool I'm in then because
you just said you're in I'm in because
you're you know I trust him so that's it
was that simple
that's great yeah I think it's a good
idea
um okay cool and I have by the way I
have a couple uh
Banger topics I'm in a uh like I have a
lot of research going on right now and
uh I'm excited there's some that I'm
like I'm like they're almost so good it
might need to be its own episode like I
want to do one that's basically breaking
down like what's actually going on with
VR like is VR kind of like dead in the
wall why is it Loki killing it like yeah
that sort of thing and so we've been
doing a bunch of research on that um
share it with me yeah and we'll do a
whole episode on it on Monday and I'll
be the straight man and I'll ask you
questions like I don't know anything
okay sounds good I think it needs
basically it's good as is but I think it
could be a lot better I actually want to
go talk to a bunch of like the VR app
developers to be like yo give me the
real deal like what are you like here's
what the data tells me but like what
yeah do you agree or disagree so I want
to talk to a few other experts which
normally I don't do that normally it's
like either that happened already
accidentally spontaneously yeah you're
not doing it it's a capital J journalism
yeah so this time I'm kind of like I
don't know going further for some reason
but I I think it's because I actually
want the answer because I want to know
if I should be investing more in this
space or not and um
dude a couple of my investments have
taken off like the first of some of the
early deals with the fund is now two
years old
and we now have two or three companies
that are like
40x to 80x returns
um not liquid yet so you know anything
can happen but
that's like a crazy multiple and it's
like
it's such a it's like so in my brain I
knew intellectually this is how it's
supposed to go you're supposed to do
this Angel Investing thing you get this
basket of companies and then you're
looking for these breakouts that are
going to return this huge you know
multiple uh 20x 30X 50s 100x thousand X
returns and then when you start to see
it actually happen you take out the
calculator app and you're like wow this
is incredible 100 000 can turn into 10
million just like that a hundred
thousand dollars could turn into 50
million if it does one more like leap
year
um and that's pretty exciting so so that
that's just been a like I don't know for
some reason that's been a
um
I don't know like a second wind in terms
of like
once things I I guess in general When
Things become real
um
things always ratchet up I've always
felt this way like the first time I took
a dividend out of my business
I was like oh okay I was I thought I was
already like you know all in but like
this made it even more real and exciting
and I'm watching it up when I thought I
was already ratcheted all the way and
the same thing's happening with the
start of investing stuff for it now as
these startups actually break out it's
like you ratcheted it up even more even
though you thought you already were but
that that tangible hit of success same
thing happened with content creation I
thought I was already trying and then oh
now we're getting 100 000 plus per
episode okay
I'm start doing research I'm start doing
more like that I was like I thought I
was already doing research but but no
now I want to push the envelope further
all right well let's do a whole thing on
VR on Monday and we'll talk about your
Investments cool we should actually do
a thing where we portfolio yeah and we
can balance it we could be like okay I
lost this much money in the stock market
and we could do a more wholesome like uh
a more holistic thing so it's not just
hey here's some wins it's like that
means I have to log in and look though
I don't even know [__] that nevermind
[Music]
foreign